With that reasoning in mind, we might expect the keyword this to be
inaccessible from the global scope as well.
Instead however, the language has historically been set up so
that you can refer to this from the global scope.
And doing so, gives you that default binding, which is to the global object.
This is another confusing aspect of the language and luckily that behavior was
removed in the more modern specifications of the language.
Finally, I'd like to cover one last way that the parameter this gets
a different sort of binding.
The pattern we're about to see here is built to support mechanisms,
we haven't explored yet and
will look at in more detail in the lesson on pseudo-classical classes.
In this situation, we're calling our function with the key word new before it.
And that will have an effect on how the keyword this receives its binding.
The positional parameters are, of course, unaffected by the keyword new.
They get passed along in exactly the same way as they always are.
But the binding for the keyword this is likely to surprise you.
It's quite possible you've encountered discussions on
the internet of how the keyword new works.
And if so, you might take a moment to conjecture what you think the binding for
this might be under these circumstances.